[Music]
shortly after my education at college
was finished
i happened to be staying at paris with
an english friend
we were both young men then and lived i
am afraid
rather a wild life in the delightful
city of our sojourn
one night we were idling about the
neighborhood of the palais royal
doubtful to what amusement we should
next be take ourselves
my friend proposed a visit to frescati's
but his suggestion was not to my taste
i knew frescati's as the french saying
is by heart
had lost and won plenty of five frank
pieces there
merely for amusement's sake until it was
amusement no longer
and was thoroughly tired in fact of all
the ghastly respectabilities of such a
social anomaly as a respectable gambling
house
for heaven's sake said i to my friend
let us go somewhere where we can see a
little genuine black guard
poverty-stricken gaming
with no false gingerbread glitter thrown
over at all
let us get away from fashionable
frescaties to a house where they don't
mind letting in a man with a ragged coat
or a man with no coat ragged or
otherwise
very well said my friend we needn't go
out of the palais royal to find the sort
of company you want
here's the place just before us as
blackguard a place by all report
as you could possibly wish to see in
another minute we arrived at the door
and entered the house the back of which
you have drawn in your sketch
when we got upstairs and had left our
hats and sticks with the door keeper
we were admitted into the chief gambling
room we did not find many people
assembled there
but few as the men were who looked up at
us on our entrance
they were all types lamentably true
types of their respective classes
we had come to see black guards but
these men were something worse
there is a comic side more or less
appreciable in all black gardism
here there was nothing but tragedy mute
weird tragedy
the quiet in the room was horrible the
thin
haggard long-haired young man whose
sunken eyes fiercely watched the turning
up of the cards
never spoke the flabby fat-faced pimply
player
who pricked his piece of pasteboard
perseveringly to register how often
black
won and how often read never spoke
the dirty wrinkled old man with the
vulture eyes and the darned great coat
who had lost his last sue and still
looked on desperately
after he could play no longer never
spoke
even the voice of the croupier sounded
as if it were strangely dulled and
thickened
in the atmosphere of the room i had
entered the place to laugh
but the spectacle before me was
something to weep over
i soon found it necessary to take refuge
and excitement from the depression of
spirits which was fast stealing on me
unfortunately i sought the nearest
excitement by going to the table and
beginning
to play still more unfortunately
as the event will show i won one
prodigiously
one incredibly one at such a rate that
the regular players at the table crowded
round me
and staring at my stakes with hungry
superstitious eyes
whispered to one another that the
english stranger was going to break the
bank
the game was rouge noir i had played at
it in every city in europe
without however the care or the wish to
study the theory of chances
that philosopher's stone of all gamblers
and a gambler in the strict sense of the
word
i never had been i was heart whole from
the corroding passion for play
my gaming was a mere idol amusement i
never resorted to it by necessity
because i never knew what it was to want
money
i never practiced it so incessantly as
to lose more than i could afford
or to gain more than i could coolly
pocket without being thrown off my
balance by my good luck
in short i had hitherto frequented
gambling tables
just as i frequented ballrooms and opera
houses because they amused me
and because i had nothing better to do
with my leisure hours
but on this occasion it was very
different now for the first time in my
life
i felt what the passion for play really
was
my success first bewildered and then in
the most literal meaning of the word
intoxicated me incredible as it may
appear
it is nevertheless true that i only lost
when i attempted to estimate chances
and played according to previous
calculation
if i left everything to luck and staked
without any care or consideration
i was sure to win to win in the face of
every recognized probability in favor of
the bank
at first some of the men present
ventured their money safely enough on my
color
but i speedily increased my stakes to
sums which they dare not risk
one after another they left off playing
and breathlessly looked on at my game
still time after time i staked higher
and higher
and still won the excitement in the room
rose to fever pitch
the silence was interrupted by a deep
muttered chorus of oaths and
exclamations in different languages
every time the gold was shoveled across
to my side of the table
even the imperturbable croupier dashed
his rake on the floor in a french fury
of astonishment at my success
but one man present preserved his
self-possession
and that man was my friend he came to my
side and whispering in english
begged me to leave the place satisfied
with what i had already gained
i must do him the justice to say that he
repeated his warnings and entreaties
several times
and only left me and went away after i
had rejected his
advice i was to all intents and purposes
gambling drunk
in terms which rendered it impossible
for him to address me again that night
shortly after he had gone a hoarse voice
behind me cried
permit me my dear sir permit me to
restore to their proper place to
napoleons which you have dropped
wonderful luck sir i pledge you my word
of honor
as an old soldier in the course of my
long experience in this sort of thing
i never saw such luck as yours never
go on sir go on boldly and break the
bank
i turned round and saw nodding and
smiling at me with inveterate civility
a tall man dressed in a frogged and
braided sir too
if i had been in my senses i should have
considered him personally
as being rather a suspicious specimen of
an old soldier
he had goggling bloodshot eyes mangy
mustaches
and a broken nose his voice betrayed a
barrick room in tonation of the worst
order
and he had the dirtiest pair of hands i
ever saw even in france
these little personal peculiarities
exercised however
no repelling influence on me in the mad
excitement
the reckless triumph of that moment i
was ready to fraternize with anybody who
encouraged me in my game
i accepted the old soldier's offered
pinch of snuff
clapped him on the back and swore he was
the honestest fellow in the world
the most glorious relic of the grand
army that i had ever met with
go on cried my military friend snapping
his fingers in ecstasy
go on and win break the bank my
gallan-english comrade break the bank
and i did go on went on at such a rate
then in another quarter of an hour the
croupier called out
gentlemen the bank has discontinued for
tonight
all the notes and all the gold in that
bank now lay in a heap under my hands
the whole floating capital of the
gambling house was waiting to pour into
my pockets
tie up the money in your pocket
handkerchief my worthy sir said the old
soldier
as i wildly plunged my hands into my
heap of gold
tie it up as we used to tie up a bit of
dinner in the grand army
your winnings are too heavy for any
breeches pockets that ever were sowed
there that's it shovel them in notes and
all
what luck stop another napoleon on the
floor
now then sir two tight double knots each
way with your honorable permission
and the money's safe feel it feel it
fortunate sir
hard and round as a cannonball if they'd
only fired such cannonballs at us at
austerlitz
if they only had and now as an ancient
grenadier
as an ex-brave of the french army what
remains for me to do
i ask what simply this to entreat my
valued english friend to drink a bottle
of champagne with me
and toast the goddess fortune and
foaming goblets before we part
excellent x-brave convivial ancient
grenadier
champagne by all means an english cheer
for an old soldier
hurrah hurrah another english cheer for
the goddess fortune
hurrah bravo the englishman
the amiable gracious englishman in whose
veins circulates the vivacious blood of
france
another glass ah the bottle is empty
never mind
i the old soldier order another bottle
and half a pound of bonbons with it
no no x brave never ancient grenadier
your bottle last time
my bottle this behold it toast away
the french army the great napoleon the
present company
the croupier the honest croupier's wife
and daughters
if he has any the ladies generally
everybody in the world
by the time the second bottle of
champagne was emptied i felt as if i had
been drinking liquid fire
my brain seemed all aflame no excess in
wine had ever had this effect on me
before in my life
was it the result of a stimulant acting
upon my system when i was in a highly
excited state
was my stomach in a particularly
disordered condition
or was the champagne amazingly strong
ex-brave of the french army cried eye in
a mad state of exhilaration
i am on fire how are you you have set me
on fire
do you hear my hero of australis let us
have a third bottle of champagne to put
the flame out
the old soldier wagged his head rolled
his goggle eyes
until i expected to see them slip out of
their sockets
placed his dirty forefinger by the side
of his broken nose
solemnly ejaculated coffee and
immediately ran
off into an inner room the word
pronounced by the eccentric veteran
seemed to have a magical effect on the
rest of the company present
with one accord they all rose to depart
probably they had expected to profit by
my intoxication
but finding that my new friend was
benevolently bent on preventing me from
getting dead drunk
had now abandoned all hope of thriving
pleasantly on my winnings
whatever their motive might be at any
rate they went away in a body
when the old soldier returned and sat
down again opposite to me at the table
we had the room to ourselves i could see
the croupier in a sort of vestibule
which opened out of it
eating his supper and solitude the
silence was now deeper than ever
a sudden change too had come over the
ex-brave
he assumed a portentously solemn look
and when he spoke to me again his speech
was ornamented by no
oaths in force by no finger snapping
enlivened by no apostrophes or
exclamations
listen my dear sir said he in
mysteriously confidential tones
listen to an old soldier's advice i have
been to the mistress of the house
a very charming woman with a genius for
cookery to impress on her the necessity
of making us
some particularly strong and good coffee
you must drink this coffee in order to
get rid of your little amiable
exaltation of spirits before you think
of going home
you must my good and gracious friend
with all that money to take home tonight
it is a sacred duty to yourself to have
your wits about you
you are known to be a winner to an
enormous extent by several gentlemen
present tonight
who in a certain point of view are very
worthy and excellent fellows
but they are mortal men my dear sir and
they have their amiable weaknesses
need i say more ah no no you understand
me
now this is what you must do send for a
cabriolet when you feel quite well again
drop all the windows when you get into
it and tell the driver to take you home
only through the large and well-lighted
thoroughfares do this
and you and your money will be safe do
this and tomorrow you will thank an old
soldier for giving you a word of honest
advice just as the ex-brave ended his
oration and very lacrimos tones
the coffee came in ready poured out in
two cups
my attentive friend handed me one of the
cups with a bow
i was parched with thirst and drank it
off at a draft
almost instantly afterwards i was seized
with a fit of giddiness
and felt more completely intoxicated
than ever
the room whirled round and round
furiously the old soldier
seemed to be regularly bobbing up and
down before me like the piston of a
steam engine
i was half deafened by a violent singing
in my ears
a feeling of utter bewilderment
helplessness idiocy
overcame me i rose from my chair
holding on by the table to keep my
balance and stammered out that i felt
dreadfully unwell
so unwell that i did not know how i was
going to get home
my dear friend answered the old soldier
and even his voice seemed to be bobbing
up and down as he spoke
my dear friend it would be madness to go
home in your state
you would be sure to lose your money you
might be robbed and murdered with the
greatest ease
i am going to sleep here do you sleep
here too
they make up capital beds in this house
take one
sleep off the effects of the wine and go
home safely with your winnings tomorrow
tomorrow in broad daylight i had but two
ideas left
one that i must never let go of my
handkerchief full of money
the other that i must lie down somewhere
immediately and fall off into a
comfortable sleep
so i agreed to the proposal about the
bed and took the offered arm of the old
soldier
carrying my money with my disengaged
hand
preceded by the croupier we passed along
some passages
and up a flight of stairs into the
bedroom which i was to occupy
the ex-brave shook me warmly by the hand
proposed that we should have breakfast
together
and then followed by the croupier left
me for the night
i ran to the wash stand drank some of
the water in my jug
poured the rest out and plunged my face
into it
then sat down in a chair and tried to
compose myself
i soon felt better the change for my
lungs from the fetid atmosphere of the
gambling room to the cool air of the
apartment i now occupied
the almost equally refreshing change
from my eyes from the glaring gaslights
of the salon to the dim quiet flicker of
one bedroom candle
aided wonderfully the restorative
effects of cold water
the giddiness left me and i began to
feel a little like a reasonable being
again
my first thought was of the risk of
sleeping all night in a gambling house
my second of the still greater risk of
trying to get out after the house was
closed
and of going home alone at night through
the streets of paris
with a large sum of money about me i had
slept in worse places than this on my
travels
so i determined to lock bolt and
barricade my door
and take my chance till the next morning
accordingly i secured myself against all
intrusion
looked under the bed and into the
cupboard tried the fastening of the
window
and then satisfied that i had taken
every proper precaution
pulled off my upper clothing put my
light which was a dim one
on the hearth among a feathery litter of
wood ashes
and got into bed with a handkerchief
full of money under my pillow
i soon felt not only that i could not go
to sleep
but that i could not even close my eyes
i was wide awake
and in a high fever every nerve in my
body trembled
every one of my senses seemed to be
preeter naturally sharpened
i tossed and rolled and tried every kind
of position
and perseveringly sought out the cold
corners of the bed
and all to no purpose now i thrust my
arms over the clothes
now i poked them under the clothes now i
violently shot my legs straight out down
to the bottom of the bed
now i convulsively coiled them up as
near my chin as they would go
now i shook out my crumpled pillow
changed it to the cool side
patted it flat and lay down quietly on
my back
now i fiercely doubled it in two set it
up on end
thrusted against the board of the bed
and tried a sitting posture
every effort was in vain i groaned with
vexation as i felt that i was in for a
sleepless night
what could i do i had no book to read
and yet unless i found out some method
of diverting my mind
i felt certain that i was in the
condition to imagine all sorts of
horrors
to rack my brain with forebodings of
every possible and impossible danger
in short to pass the night in suffering
all conceivable varieties of nervous
terror
i raised myself on my elbow and looked
about the room
which was brightened by a lovely
moonlight pouring straight through the
window
to see if it contained any pictures or
ornaments that i could at all clearly
distinguish
while my eyes wandered from wall to wall
a remembrance of le maestra's delightful
little book
voyage a tour de machame occurred to me
i resolved to imitate the french author
and find occupation and amusement enough
to relieve the tedium of my wakefulness
by making a mental inventory of every
article of furniture i could see
and by following up to their sources the
multitude of associations which even a
chair
a table or a wash stand may be made to
call forth
in the nervous unsettled state of my
mind at that moment
i found it much easier to make my
inventory than to make my reflections
and there upon soon gave up all hope of
thinking in le maestro's fanciful track
or indeed of thinking at all i looked
about the room at the different articles
of furniture
and did nothing more there was first
the bed i was lying in a four-post bed
of all things in the world to meet with
in paris yes
a thorough clumsy british four poster
with a regular top lined with chintz
the regular fringed valance all round
the regular stifling
unwholesome curtains which i remembered
having mechanically drawn back against
the posts
without particularly noticing the bed
when i first got into the room
then there was the marble topped wash
stand from which the water i had spilled
in my hurry to pour it out was still
dripping slowly and more slowly
onto the brick floor then two small
chairs
with my coat waistcoat and trousers
flung on them
then a large elbow chair covered with
dirty white dimity
with my cravat and shirt collar thrown
over the back
then a chest of drawers with two of the
brass handles off
and a tawdry broken china ink stand
placed on it by way of ornament for the
top
then the dressing table adorned by a
very small looking glass
and a very large pin cushion then the
window
an unusually large window then a dark
old picture
which the feeble candle dimly showed me
it was a picture of a fellow in a high
spanish hat
crowned with a plume of towering
feathers a swarthy sinister ruffian
looking upward shading his eyes with his
hand and looking intently upward
it might be at some tall gallows at
which he was going to be hanged
at any rate he had the appearance of
thoroughly deserving it
this picture put a kind of constraint
upon me to look upward to
at the top of the bed it was a gloomy
and not an interesting object
and i looked back at the picture i
counted the feathers in the man's hat
they stood out in relief three white two
green
i observed the crown of his hat which
was of conical shape
according to the fashion supposed to
have been favored by guido fox
i wondered what he was looking up at it
couldn't be at the stars
such a desperado was neither astrologer
nor astronomer
it must be at the high gallows and he
was going to be hanged presently
would the executioner come into
possession of his conical crowned hat
and plume of feathers
i counted the feathers again three white
two green
while i still lingered over this very
improving and intellectual employment
my thoughts insensibly began to wander
the moonlight shining into the room
reminded me of a certain moonlight night
in england
the night after a picnic party in a
welsh valley
every incident of the drive homeward
through lovely scenery
which the moonlight made lovelier than
ever came back to my remembrance
though i had never given the picnic a
thought for years
though if i had tried to recollect it i
could certainly have recalled little or
nothing of that scene long past
of all the wonderful faculties that help
to tell us we are immortal
which speaks the sublime truth more
eloquently than memory
here was i in a strange house of the
most suspicious character
in a situation of uncertainty and even
of peril
which might seem to make the cool
exercise of my recollection
almost out of the question nevertheless
remembering
quite involuntarily places people
conversations
minute circumstances of every kind which
i had thought forgotten forever
which i could not possibly have recalled
at will even under the most favorable
auspices
and what cause had produced in a moment
the whole of this strange complicated
mysterious effect
nothing but some rays of moonlight
shining in at my bedroom window
i was still thinking of the picnic of
our merriment on the drive home
of the sentimental young lady who would
quote child harold
because it was moonlight i was absorbed
by these past scenes and past amusements
when in an instant
the thread on which my memories hung
snapped us under
my attention immediately came back to
present things more vividly than ever
and i found myself i neither knew why
nor wherefore
looking hard at the picture again
looking for what
good god the man had pulled his hat down
on his brows
no the hat itself was gone where was the
conical crown
where the feathers three white two green
not there
in the place of the hat and feathers
what dusky object was it that now hid
his forehead
his eyes his shading hand
was the bed moving i turned on my back
and looked up
was i mad drunk dreaming giddy again
or was the top of the bed really moving
down
sinking slowly regularly silently
horribly right down throughout the hole
of its length and breadth
right down upon me as i lay underneath
my blood seemed to stand still a deadly
paralyzing coldness stole all over me as
i turned my head round on the pillow
and determined to test whether the bed
top was really moving or not
by keeping my eye on the man in the
picture
the next look in that direction was
enough the dull black frowsey outline of
the valance above me was within an inch
of being parallel with his waist
i still looked breathlessly and steadily
and slowly
very slowly i saw the figure and the
line of frame below the figure
vanish as the valance moved down before
it
i am constitutionally anything but timid
i have been on more than one occasion
and peril of my life
and have not lost my self-possession for
an instant
but when the conviction first settled on
my mind that the bed top was really
moving
was steadily and continuously sinking
down upon me
i looked up shuddering helpless
panic-stricken
beneath the hideous machinery for murder
which was advancing closer and closer to
suffocate me where i lay
i looked up motionless speechless
breathless
the candle fully spent went out but the
moonlight still brightened the room
down and down without pausing without
sounding came the bed top
and still my panicked terror seemed to
bind me faster and faster to the
mattress on which i lay
down and down it sank till the dusty
odor from the lining of the canopy came
stealing into my nostrils
at that final moment the instinct of
self-preservation startled me out of my
trance
and i moved at last there was just room
for me to roll myself
sidewise off the bed as i dropped
noiselessly to the floor
the edge of the murderous canopy touched
me on the shoulder
without stopping to draw my breath
without wiping the cold sweat from my
face
i rose instantly on my knees to watch
the bed top
i was literally spellbound by it if i
had heard footsteps behind me
i could not have turned round if a means
of escape had been miraculously provided
for me
i could not have moved to take advantage
of it the whole life in me was at that
moment
concentrated in my eyes it descended
the whole canopy with the fringe round
it came down
down close down so close that there was
not room now to squeeze my finger
between the bed top and the bed
i felt at the sides and discovered that
what had appeared to me from beneath to
be the ordinary light canopy of a
four-post bed
was in reality a thick broad mattress
the substance of which was concealed by
the valance in its fringe
i looked up and saw the four posts
rising hideously bare
in the middle of the bed top was a huge
wooden screw
that had evidently worked it down
through a hole in the ceiling
just as ordinary presses are worked down
on the substance selected for
compression
the frightful apparatus moved without
making the faintest noise
there had been no creaking as it came
down there was now not the faintest
sound from the room above
amid a dead and awful silence i beheld
before me
in the 19th century and in the civilized
capital of france
such a machine for secret murder by
suffocation
as might have existed in the worst days
of the inquisition
in the lonely inns among the hearts
mountains in the mysterious tribunals of
westphalia
still as i looked on it i could not move
i could hardly breathe
but i began to recover the power of
thinking and in a moment i discovered
the murderous conspiracy framed against
me
in all its horror my cup of coffee had
been drugged
and drugged too strongly i had been
saved from being smothered by having
taken an overdose of some narcotic
how i had chafed and fretted at the
fever fit which had preserved my life by
keeping me awake
how recklessly i had confided myself to
the two wretches who had led me into
this room
determined for the sake of my winnings
to kill me in my sleep
by the surest and most horrible
contrivance for secretly accomplishing
my destruction
how many men winners like me had slept
as i had proposed to sleep in that bed
and had never been seen or heard of more
i shuddered at the bare idea of it but
here long
all thought was again suspended by the
sight of the murderous canopy moving
once more
after it had remained on the bed as
nearly as i could guess
about 10 minutes it began to move up
again
the villains who worked it from above
evidently believed that their purpose
was now accomplished
slowly and silently as it had descended
that horrible bed top
rose towards its former place when it
reached the upper extremities of the
four posts
it reached the ceiling too neither hole
nor screw could be seen
the bed became an appearance an ordinary
bed again
the canopy an ordinary canopy even to
the most suspicious eyes
now for the first time i was able to
move to rise from my knees
to dress myself in my upper clothing and
to consider of how i should escape
if i betrayed by the smallest noise that
the attempt to suffocate me had failed
i was certain to be murdered had i made
any noise already
i listened intently looking towards the
door
no no footsteps in the passage outside
no sound of a tread light or heavy in
the room above
absolute silence everywhere besides
locking and bolting my door
i had moved an old wooden chest against
it which i had found under the bed
to remove this chest my blood ran cold
as i thought of what its contents might
be
without making some disturbance was
impossible and moreover
to think of escaping through the house
now barred up for the night
with sheer insanity only one chance was
left me
the window i stole to it on tiptoe
my bedroom was on the first floor above
an antrasol
and looked into a back street which you
have sketched in your view
i raised my hand to open the window
knowing that on that action hung
by the merest hair breath my chance of
safety
they keep vigilant watch in a house of
murder
if any part of the frame cracked if the
hinge creaked
i was a lost man it must have occupied
me at least five minutes
reckoning by time five hours reckoning
by suspense
to open that window i succeeded in doing
it silently
and doing it with all the dexterity of a
house breaker and then looked down into
the street
to leap the distance beneath me would be
almost certain destruction
next i looked round at the sides of the
house
down the left side ran a thick water
pipe which you have drawn
it passed close by the outer edge of the
window
the moment i saw the pipe i knew i was
saved
my breath came and went freely for the
first time since i had seen the canopy
of the bed moving down upon me
to some men the means of escape which i
had discovered might have seemed
difficult and dangerous enough
to me the prospect of slipping down the
pipe into the street did not suggest
even a thought of peril i had always
been accustomed by the practice of
gymnastics
to keep up my schoolboy powers as a
daring and expert climber
and knew that my head hands and feet
would serve me faithfully
in any hazards of ascent or descent i
had already got one leg over the
windowsill
when i remembered the handkerchief
filled with money under my pillow
i could well have afforded to leave it
behind me but i was revengefully
determined that the miscreants of the
gambling house
should miss their plunder as well as
their victim
so i went back to the bed and tied the
heavy handkerchief at my back by my
cravat
just as i had made it tight and fixed it
in a comfortable place
i thought i heard a sound of breathing
outside the door
the chill feeling of horror ran through
me again as i listened
no dead silence still in the passage
i had only heard the night air blowing
softly into the room
the next moment i was on the windowsill
and the next i had a firm grip on the
water pipe with my hands and knees
i slid down into the street easily and
quietly as i thought i should
and immediately set off at the top of my
speed to a branch prefecture of police
which i knew was situated in the
immediate neighborhood
a sub-prefect and several picked men
among his subordinates
happened to be up maturing i believe
some scheme for discovering the
perpetrator of a mysterious murder which
all paris was talking of just then
when i began my story in a breathless
hurry and in very bad french
i could see that the sub-prefect
suspected me of being a drunken
englishman who had robbed somebody
but he soon altered his opinion as i
went on and before i had anything like
concluded
he shoved all the papers before him into
a drawer put on his hat
supplied me with another for i was
bareheaded ordered a file of soldiers
desired his expert followers to get
ready all sorts of tools for breaking
open doors and ripping up brick flooring
and took my arm in the most friendly and
familiar manner possible
to lead me with him out of the house i
will venture to say that when the sub
prefect was a little boy and was taken
for the first time to the play
he was not half as much pleased as he
was now at the job and prospect for him
at the gambling house
away we went through the streets the
sub-prefect cross-examining and
congratulating me in the same breath as
we marched at the head of our formidable
posse comatadas
sentinels were placed at the back in
front of the house the moment we got to
it
a tremendous battery of knocks was
directed against the door
a light appeared at a window i was told
to conceal myself behind the police
then came more knocks and a cry of open
in the name of the law
at that terrible summons bolts and locks
gave way before an invisible hand
and the moment after the sub-prefect was
in the passage
confronting a waiter half-dressed and
ghastly pale
this was the short dialogue which
immediately took place
we want to see the englishman who is
sleeping in this house
he went away hours ago he did no such
thing
his friend went away he remained show us
to his bedroom
i swear to you sir he is not here he i
swear to you garcon he is
he slept here he didn't find your bed
comfortable
he came to us to complain of it here he
is among my men
and here am i ready to look for a flea
or two in his bedstead
he called to one of his subordinates and
pointed to the waiter
collar that man and tie his hands behind
him now then gentlemen
let us walk upstairs every man and woman
in the house was secured
the old soldier the first then i
identified the bed in which i had slept
and then we went into the room above no
object that was at all extraordinary
appeared in any part of it the
sub-prefect
looked round the place commanded
everybody to be silent
stamped twice on the floor called for a
candle
looked attentively at the spot he had
stamped on and ordered the flooring
there to be carefully taken up
this was done in no time lights were
produced
and we saw a deep raftered cavity
between the floor of this room and the
ceiling of the room beneath
through this cavity there ran
perpendicularly a sort of case of iron
thickly greased
and inside the case appeared the screw
which communicated with the bed top
below
extra lengths of screw freshly oiled
levers covered with felt
all the complete upper works of a heavy
press constructed with infernal
ingenuity so as to join the fixtures
below
and when taken to pieces again to go
into the smallest possible compass
where next discovered and pulled out
onto the floor
after some little difficulty the
sub-prefect succeeded in putting the
machinery together
and leaving his men to work it descended
with me to the bedroom
the smothering canopy was then lowered
but not so noiselessly as i had seen it
lowered
when i mentioned this to the sub-prefect
his answer simple as it was
had a terrible significance my men
said he are working down the bed top for
the first time
the men whose money you won were in
better practice
we left the house in the sole possession
of two police agents
every one of the inmates being removed
to prison on the spot
the sub-prefect after taking down my
process verbal in his office
returned with me to my hotel to get my
passport
do you think i asked as i gave it to him
that any men have really been smothered
in that bed
as they tried to smother me i have seen
dozens of drowned men laid out at the
morgue
answered the sub prefect and whose
pocket books were found letters stating
that they had committed suicide in the
sen
because they had lost everything at the
gaming table
do i know how many of those men entered
the same gambling house that you entered
one as you won took that bed as you took
it
slept in it were smothered in it and
were privately thrown into the river
with a letter of explanation written by
the murderers and placed in their
pocketbooks
no man can say how many or how few have
suffered the fate from which you have
escaped
the people of the gambling house kept
their bedstead machinery a secret from
us
even from the police the dead kept the
rest of the secret for them
good night or rather good morning mr
faulkner
be at my office again at nine o'clock in
the meantime au revoir the rest of my
story is soon told
i was examined and re-examined the
gambling house was strictly searched all
through from top to bottom
the prisoners were separately
interrogated and two of the less guilty
among them made a confession
i discovered that the old soldier was
the master of the gambling house
justice discovered that he had been
drummed out of the army as a vagabond
years ago
that he had been guilty of all sorts of
villainies since
that he was in possession of stolen
property which the owners identified
and that he the croupier another
accomplice and the woman who had made my
cup of coffee
were all in the secret of the bedstead
there appeared some reason to doubt
whether the inferior persons attached to
the house
knew anything of the suffocating
machinery and they received the benefit
of that doubt
by being treated simply as thieves and
vagabonds
as for the old soldier and his two head
myrmadons
they went to the galleys the woman who
had drugged my coffee was imprisoned for
i forget how many years
the regular attendants at the gambling
house were considered suspicious
and placed under surveillance and i
became for one whole week
which is a long time the head lion in
parisian society
my adventure was dramatized by three
illustrious playmakers
but never saw theatrical daylight for
the censorship forbade the introduction
on the stage of a correct copy of the
gambling house bedstead
one good result was produced by my
adventure which any censorship must have
approved
it cured me of ever again trying roux
noir as an amusement
the sight of a green cloth with packs of
cards and heaps
of money on it will henceforth be
forever associated in my mind with the
sight of a bed canopy descending to
suffocate me
in the silence and darkness of the night
just as mr faulkner pronounced these
words he started in his chair
and resumed his stiff dignified position
in a great hurry
bless my soul cried he with a comic look
of astonishment and vexation
while i have been telling you what is
the real secret of my interest in the
sketch you have so kindly given to me
i have altogether forgotten that i came
here to sit for my portrait
for the last hour or more i must have
been the worst model you ever had to
draw from
on the contrary you have been the best
said i
i have been trying to catch your
likeness and while telling your story
you have unconsciously shown me the
natural expression i wanted to ensure my
success
note by mrs kirby i cannot let this
story end without mentioning what the
chance saying was
which caused it to be told at the
farmhouse the other night
our friend the young sailor among his
other quaint objections to sleeping on
shore
declared that he particularly hated four
post beds
because he never slept in one without
doubting whether the top might not come
down in the night and suffocate him
i thought this chance referenced to the
distinguishing feature of william's
narrative
curious enough and my husband agreed
with me but he says it is scarcely
worthwhile to mention such a trifle in
anything so important as a book
i cannot venture after this to do more
than slip these lines in modestly
at the end of the story if the printer
should notice my last few words
perhaps he may not mind the trouble of
putting them into some out of the way
corner
you